Would you like to learn
more about Kiosk Apps?
I'm Vidya, and I'll help you
explore what Kiosk Apps can do
and how you can build them.
Hang on tight, and
enjoy the ride.
Unleash the power of
Kiosk Apps with me.
First, let's see some
single-purpose devices
in action.
Although you might
not even realize it,
these devices are
all around you.
Here is a restaurant cafe
with an interactive display
showing the menu and
specials for the day.
A customer can walk
up to a display
and scan the QR code for
a chance to win a meal.
You might also find a
device at a doctor's office
where patients check
in and wait their turn.
Many grocery stores now support
self-serve point of sale kiosks
where customers can scan
items and pay for them.
Self-serve kiosks are also
appearing at movie theaters
where guests can
purchase tickets.
An innovative application is
an integrated library catalog,
and they find our kiosk
showing the map of the library
building.
A guest can browse
the collection,
determine if a
book is available,
and locate the section
that contains the book.
These devices are also used
in educational environments.
Here is a fifth grade
class where students
are taking online tests
in a locked-down, secured
environment.
All of the single-purpose
use cases you just saw
could be powered by Kiosk
Apps running on Chromeboxes.
The possibilities are
limitless-- gaming consoles,
photobooths, displays in
public transportation,
billboards, ATM machines.
All of this can be
powered by Kiosk Apps.
Did you know that the
displays and registration
Kiosks at Google
I/O have also been
powered by Kiosk
Apps on Chromeboxes?
You may ask why
would a Chromebox
be the best choice
to run a Kiosk.
Well, there are many reasons.
Chromeboxes are fast and secure.
You no longer have to
worry about OS patches
or install antivirus software.
OS updates are taken care
of automatically for you.
Further, the OS and the
Kiosk App running on it
have independent update cycles.
So as an app developer, you
only have to update your app
and Chrome OS keeps
the rest fresh.
And with the Chrome
management console,
you can easily
deploy and remotely
manage a fleet of
Chromeboxes that
maybe distributed
around the world.
A Kiosk App is just a Chrome app
with HTML, CSS, and JavaScript.
You can build powerful apps
that interact with network
and hybrid devices, media
tools, and much more.
You can enhance
the user experience
through touch, with
virtual keyboard support,
and by listening for
mouth and touch events.
For example, you can build
a point of sale Kiosk App
that uses the Chrome USB API
to communicate with USB devices
like barcode scanners, credit
card readers, and printers.
You can also use
the Bluetooth API
to talk to Bluetooth devices.
However, there are
indeed some differences
between Kiosk and
regular Chrome apps.
Now, consider the display
at an airport terminal
using an interactive Kiosk App.
The app is set to auto-launch
when the Chromebox first boots
up and always runs
in full screen,
providing a dedicated
user experience.
Here I check on the status of
the flight from Minneapolis
on one of the displays and
click on "Southwest flight
SWA3236" for more information.
The app updates
the flight tracker
with the route map
of that flight.
I realize that the
flight has been delayed
and want to get
something to eat.
I can scan the QR
code on the display
and grab the flight information
for me to look at on my phone
while I'm in transit.
I now click on "Dining"
which brings up
a map with the nearest
places to eat along
with restaurant ratings.
I decide to go to
Fresh Roll Vietnamese
as it's got the best
ratings and it's close by.
Google Maps gives me
directions to help
me get to the restaurant.
As a bonus, I can also redeem
a coupon for a combo meal
if I scan the QR code on
the display with my phone.
I can also click on "Weather,"
get the five-day local weather
forecast, and get some fast
facts about the airport.
It's interesting that there
were 31,000 check-ins today.
Lots of travel indeed.
You might have noticed that,
when this app is running,
the user cannot exit the app
or switch to another task.
However, the app could
offer a logout button
that allows the user
to close all windows
and terminate the session.
To convert a Chrome app into a
Kiosk App, all you need to do
is add the attributes
Kiosk Enabled and Kiosk
Only to the manifest.json file
to ensure that the app will
only run in full-screen
using single-app Kiosk Mode.
After writing a Kiosk
App, you can publish it
to the Chrome Web Store.
You can either monetize the app
or just use the app in-house.
You can also test the app
in single-app Kiosk Mode
by firing up a browser
and add the Kiosk App
at the Chrome Extensions page.
Installed Kiosk Apps will
now appear in the tree,
under "Apps," in
the login screen.
You can then manually
launch the app from the tree
and test the app.
As an app developer, you can
choose to download and cache
any assets you need so that,
the next time your user
launches the app, the
cached assets are available
immediately, even when offline.
The Chrome management
console can then
be used to deploy an app
to a fleet of Chromeboxes.
There is also an option
to automatically launch
the app on the Chromebox when
the device first boots up.
We're excited to see what
kind of apps you will build.
You can take it for a spin today
by going to the links here.
There are sample Kiosk Apps
that you can play with.
Let us know what you think,
and thanks for watching.